all right so thanks for sticking around
till the last
talk of the last session of the last day
of the workshop
uh okay so i'll talk ab this is uh
i'll talk about computer information
complexity and it's a
joint work with my student john
schneider
so the the basic setup is one that
you've seen many times so just to be
specific
we have alice and bob they have shared
randomness and they're doing something
with the protocol in this case they're
computing it's actually it matters that
they're trying to compute some function
f of x y
which means that both of them and then
have the value of f of x y
uh okay so this is the setup the zero
error information complexity
is what they reveal to each other while
they speak so it's a function of two
things it's a
uh they sorry let's take it a bit more
slowly
this is the information cost of a
protocol is what the protocol reveals
to the players and it's a function of
both the protocol and the prior
distribution
and the zero error information
complexity of a function
is the infimum overall protocols
of this quantity of what so it's the
least amount of information
that you need to review in order to
solve
the problem with zero error and it's
it's a bit
important that even if mu doesn't have
full support
to correctly compute means to correctly
compute on all inputs
that's a minor technical point but so
basically i want to look at all the
protocols that always do the right thing
they're allowed to use randomness
particularly private randomness and
that's important
and i want to reveal as little
information as possible
and this quantity is operational in that
if you take the amortized communication
complexity with vanishing error
uh then it's actually equal in the limit
to this quantity
and the
one way to think about the discussion
today is actually understanding how
efficiently this is
what's the rate of convergence okay so
here is the compute
the computation problem we are given a
truth table of f let's say f is boolean
that's not very important
and a distribution mu
so luckily the information complex is
actually continuous in mu
so you don't need to terribly worry
about that let's assume it's just
given you in binary with some that
those are dyadic numbers and the goal is
given
a number delta produce a delta
approximation of the information
complexity of f is the distribution
uh okay so with communication complexity
it's a it's a worst case notion but even
if it was
average case it would be pretty easy to
brute force
the problem all i have to do so okay so
no function has more communication
complexity than log the size of the
input
or not much more so just brute force all
the protocol trees
of depth that or maybe a little bit over
that
it's not fun it's not pleasant but at
least it's
doable it's a search of a refining set
of things so
at least that's why 2015 you don't see
many computability questions because
most
of the things that are computable are
easy
uh so it can be brute force ic cannot be
brute force unfortunately and the reason
is that you have this infimum here
and it's there for a reason actually uh
i conjecture that for most problems
you cannot realize this quantities then
you find it protocol
so basically it's you get the sequence
of protocols they approach
the limit as they grow longer and longer
and no specific longer protocols
actually can give you a lower ic
and this is already true for the 2b10
function which is the simplest kind of
function that actually computes as
opposed to moving data around
already there you you get that the
information
if you restrict yourself to our round or
r bit protocols the information
complexity of and you so you get the
term that you would get in the limit
plus an a a second order term that's
like 1 over r squared
so that means that you need many rounds
if you want to approach
the limit
in the case of 0 error expected
communication
you still have the issue that the
protocols can be longer and longer
right it's not completely trivial it's
almost trivial so what you do
you pick some delta you run for
log n over delta if did that didn't
succeed you become frustrated and just
exchange the inputs
and that modification doesn't cost you
much or
it's it's yeah it's not completely
obvious but it's
it's a simple not exactly
right so uh here we are also trying to
compute up to delta
i mean all it's a it's potentially an
irrational number so
even for this this is a we have a kind
of a formula for it
an equation that it's all but it's an
irrational number so all you can do
is compute approximations um
okay so it turns out that if you
restrict yourself to our round protocols
and that's
something that's been discussed by uh
alone in the morning uh
it's it becomes a much easier problem so
you can compute it
um so maya and ishwar do it using one
technique
another approach is actually if you use
this result it's also
is true for our rounds and there you
have it
you can have more explicit bounds on the
rate of convergence
so basically this result would tell you
that to compute this
it would give you it would tell you what
n to take
such that if you compute this quantity
with f to the n
then this is within delta of each other
and then you could just communication
complexity you can brute force
so that's that's one way to get an
algorithm this is nice because
if you hate because this approach would
require you to
to do some analysis with continuous
functions it's doable but
it's more work than just enumerating
communication protocols if you're just
trying to get
an a computability result
okay so this okay so unfortunate so what
is the problem the problem is that
unfortunately
it's not clear how to generalize this
without in our without they are
so what we get is is a decree
non-increasing sequence of numbers
that converges to the answer but we
don't know the rate of convergence so we
don't know how many terms to take
and you can imagine this is a there are
many ways to get such a sequence another
way is just to enumerate all the
protocols there are accountably many of
them
just go over all of them and every time
list the best one you have so far but
again
it's not clear where to stop so say r is
10 to the 10 to the 10 and
you're stuck at some number maybe after
some more steps it will actually drop
and there are examples like this so
pretty much any non-computability
problem where the answer is that it's
not computable is because
something like this happens that the
word problem
doesn't you can't match it for the for
10 to the 10 to 10 but then suddenly it
does match
uh okay so the main theorem is
essentially it's a it's about
understanding protocols more so than
about
uh computation so basically the main
theorem is is an effective rate of
convergence that says that
if you have a function from a times b
then if you want to be within epsilon
it's enough to look at protocols that
have
w rounds where w something like n over
epsilon to the n
i don't think that the bound is tight
but this is
a a bound and that's enough
by what i previously said it's enough to
actually com
give an algorithm that computes the
information complexity even with some
run-in time guarantee but not a very
impressive one
um okay so that's
uh that's the main result in the caloric
as a corollary
we get an algorithm
that works by as i said just take enough
copies and
which where enough depends on this w
enumerate all the protocols for f with
that many copies look at the amortized
communication and that will be within
epsilon of the answer
okay so that's uh so the but the main
the main theorem is
is really this and uh
okay one thing that i should point out
so if you
haven't seen this problem before it's a
it's it's a very annoying problem in
that
it's actually it's hard to believe that
it's hard in some sense
uh it's very easy to almost solve it
but somehow it's actually
it took took a while and uh somehow
it's it's elusive in that it looks like
you almost solved it but then you
realize that
the details don't work out and the
details actually matter
yeah what kind of problem is it is a
convex non-convex of what type
so you can write a continuous set of
convex inequalities
so it's like if you know the dirichlet
problem for example that's a convex
equality so to compute
a harmonic function given boundary
conditions so
geometrically it's similar but the
problem is that you don't
are not allowed inequalities in all
directions because you're only allowed
inequalities that are generated by valid
messages
and so it's it's that's what it's kind
of a combination of a discrete
and a continuous component if it was
just continuous you could probably use
some
approximation through but it's it's
almost like things you get from like
mark of decision processes
and on continuous spaces and but control
theory literature we looked at actually
it was no help
either maybe so very so eventually we
had to drill down
and understand protocols so that's what
i'll talk about
in the next 15 minutes so what the proof
okay so what is the proof about the
proof
is about converting a protocol pi into
an equivalent protocol
that has only wrong so you start from
the definition of ic
for any epsilon there is a pro a finite
protocol that is within epsilon of the
information
complexity and the problem is to
convert it into a protocol that has some
structure finite structure
which we can enumerate so this is the
problem
you're given a protocol convert it into
a protocol with not too many rounds
that has the same does the same thing
and has the same cost
or almost the same cost obviously you
cannot get the same cost
and this is done in a number of steps
where at each step you
add a little bit more structure and
eventually you have
this structure that there are w rounds
okay so the first step is to understand
what is the protocol what
what are general protocols made of
and in information complexity it's
actually
private randomness is better than public
randomness you can always
uh simulate public randomness with
private randomness but not vice versa
because if you want public coins let
alice take her private coins and publish
them
this is crazy from communication
perspective but from information
perspective it costs zero okay so we can
deal with private coin protocols
and what what is a private coin protocol
for each history age
if it's alice's say turn to speak there
is a c
there is a function that tells alice
given your
input this is the probability with which
your next bit is one
so it's a function from a to zero one
a is the set of alice's inputs that on
on
input x alice will produce
a bernoulli random variable with
probability sigma h of x
that's that's what the protocol is i i
didn't do anything yet
so and the proof proceeds in three steps
the first step is is to reduce the
number of types
of signals that we use so maybe
you could use the same signal many many
times but the diff
the number of different functions that
you use should be bounded
in terms of n and epsilon and the second
step
is to convert that into a protocol that
actually uses a bounded number of rounds
and from there is what i said before
this can be used to
approximate that becomes a bounded round
ac
which can be approximately deficient
okay so the first step with almost
without with a little work we can make
all the signals very weak
how because you can always take a signal
and break it into my
many much weaker signals that do the
same thing
so as a first step we can make all the
signals very weak
and roughly of the same power where you
define
the power in a proper way
so all the signals uh are very weak and
have roughly the same power but they
could be
a lot of different kinds it's like a
sphere a multi-dimensional sphere
of possible signals and as a first step
we reduce the number of distinct signals
by using uh by
getting some ethernet on the set of
possible signals
so we replace each signal by a convex
combination of its neighbors on the net
and uh so well how do we do it
well you just represent it like this and
then you use
public randomness or which we assume we
can
get it from private run you sample z
according to this distribution alpha
and then alice sends the signal
according to one of these conventional
sigmas
so notice that this is done publicly so
the only
actual step is this one so now the only
signals used
are signals from the pre-approved list
from this episode
from this ethernet uh unfortunately okay
so this is a perfect simulation because
you can see that this signal is actually
distributed accord
exactly like the original signal the
only problem is that it reveals
additional information well the
information revealed is what z and sigma
z reveal together
it's actually convenient to first look
at what sigma z
reveals and then what z reveals what
sigma z reveals is exactly what sigma
was revealing before because it's the
same
it's distributed exactly the same how
many bits does each signal correspond to
one it's a boolean function it's a
function from
the input space to to the interval zero
one
so this net is on the space
of a the size of a so to represent each
point you need
this many neighbors is is the size of
alice's input
okay so the main point is that you can
bound it it's not hard to bound it but
the important point is that you bound it
relatively to the in terms relative to
the
value of sigma so it's sigma it's
whatever sigma reveals times some little
of epsilon term and this
is important because sigma can be very
very very very very
weak signal we don't have any control so
far
on how small sigma is and so you have
you have to do it in relative terms so
that's the first step
so why are we not done because there are
this many so
the the net is of some size that only
depends on epsilon
n but the signals can be very weak and
you could have many many copies of the
same signal so this tree
we are guaranteed that there is only few
different species
so each cartoon represents one type of
signal
so there are a few different species on
this tree but
each specie can appear many times and so
far we don't have any control
on how many times each kind of so it
could be
very very weak signals that appear very
many times and we have no control over
that
so what was the role of the delta why
did you have to
be close to half because otherwise this
inequality
these inequalities rely on some
effective compactness when you're close
to
zero or one you're in trouble actually i
only need to stay away from zero and one
i think
at that point no but also i want all of
them to be of this
roughly the same power because otherwise
so i can get an epsilon net on the
sphere
but i cannot get a finite epsilon net on
the ball
because there are many scales going in
depth so i need them to be roughly
of the same power that's that's another
reason
uh okay so but if you lost me
let's uh reconvene uh
so now we are we have q different
signals and we need to convert it into a
protocol that uses few rounds
so what's how can you do it how how you
can you can
so you have this q different species how
can you control the number of rounds
well you bundle signals of the same type
so when alice needs to send sigma to bob
she will instead take t copies of sigma
so generate iad t copies of signal sigma
put them in a box and send it to bob
okay and next time bob needs one of this
type of signals instead of
asking expecting alice to get it he will
just take
one out of a book of the box and use
that to continue the
the protocol and they'll do it until for
the next t-minus one rounds until he
runs out then
he needs to order more okay so that's
that's the basic idea
and how many do you put in this box
well that's how you that's the main
issue in this
step which is i think the main step
picture so
you nee so this bundling by the way
again achieves perfect simulation
so what what i just said doesn't hurt
the performance of the protocol
the only thing that it hurts is
that if by the end of the protocol you
have some unused signals
that's information wasted you received
something you paid for it and you didn't
use it
so uh if you select t to be too large
in the end you get stuck with too much
signals which you have to pay for
because you learn from them if you make
t2 small
then you'll need to reorder many times
so you'll get too many rounds
so essentially you need to get t large
enough
and we select t to be roughly epsilon
over q
such that that right because in the uh
so
okay so we select such that the total
value
of the size of this this box is roughly
epsilon over q let's see the intuition
in the end you get stuck with q boxes
right
with q different types of signals i want
the amount of waste of each type to be
something like this and then i'm in good
shape because
i'm stuck with the total of epsilon
unused inventory
okay so how do we decide about
on t well we look at how much
information
do these are t signals worth so if
already one signal
is bigger than the size of a box so like
this then we
just make t equals to one and we get
one signal and in that case we waste
nothing actually
now otherwise we look for the smallest s
such that s signals together reveal
between epsilon over 2 q
and epsilon over q information so this
is kind of the
typical case right so we fill up the box
between half full and full and send it
and the third case it's actually
signals their effect is submodular so
the more signals you get the less value
you get
out of them so it's possible it's
actually to be expected that eventually
even an infinite number of signals will
not be able to fill one box because
information doesn't grow forever and in
that case you just
send some maximum length so it doesn't
matter really what you do
okay so those are the three cases uh
so why uh so first of all we need to see
why they're exhaustive but they pretty
much said it already so
before even i explain that notice that
these quantities are compute can be
computed by both alice and bob
they don't need to know they don't
depend on their inputs they're
quantities about random variables so
this is a well-defined protocol and
to see that those cases are exhaustive
you need some submodularity properties
that
the more signals i send the less
marginal utility i get from the next one
so either the first signal is enough or
the first signal puts
me in this case or the first signal is
worse less than epsilon over 2q
in which case when i keep adding signals
the step size will be less than epsilon
over 2q
so either i'll eventually hit this
interval
or i'll get stuck forever below
spicer 3 this is the uh trans
this is like the history
this is the history essentially so this
is think about it as the history of the
cur
of uh of the original protocol even
uh yeah okay so the
so the information waste as i explained
is at most one box per signal
and the number of rounds well
there it comes back to this question
about
uh average so the it you would expect
so the the most the protocol can reveal
is log n bits of information
so if the size of every and the size of
every box is at least
epsilon over to q except for the q boxes
at the end so it's at most q plus
uh 2 q log n over epsilon and that would
be correct except
it's a an average case quantity and not
a worst case quantity
so we are forced to use markov once more
to agree so this is how much you would
expect
it to last this is how many boxes you
would expect to send it worst case
even if you're revealing login
information and then get another factor
because we have to use markov
to say that this happens probability one
minus epsilon
so we we go for this many rounds
and with we
then we fail with a very small
probability in which case we can
exchange the inputs
so if if we fail after this many rounds
we just
spend one more round exchange the inputs
and this happens with such a low
probability
that we can afford it uh
so what we get is this that w
rounds suffice for
uh an explicit w
and you compute you this as i discussed
to complete the construction
i'll spare you that part uh
okay so just to summarize this is the
main results
that this can be done in some
exponential
time double or triple exponential time
but
i i'm not sure it should be somewhat
improvable but notice that even
communication complexity is not
so easy to compute so maybe you can
shave one or two exponents out of it but
it's never going to be super efficient
because
you're just computing the communication
complexity from truth table so
and basically it
the the proof went in several steps
converting
at each step simplifying by somewhat
reducing the number of different
signals then bundling signals together
to reduce the number of rounds
and then computing the information
complex
best information complexity with this
number of rounds
so some open problems so first of all to
generalize this
so this is for uh zero error
uh and generalizing for epsilon error
uh i think that it just would require
more technical work
i don't i think this should be doable i
have no doubt that it's computable
but uh it requires some more work
the most important problem in my opinion
sorry
is is understanding this rate of
convergence this dependence on the
number of rounds
so from this paper we get this upper
bound that it's
there to get within epsilon you need r
that is at most
n over epsilon to the n
in the opposite direction we have
uh that for two bit end
r of epsilon is at least one over root
epsilon so notice that
here n is 4. so at least it means that
when
n is constant it should be polynomial in
epsilon and this bound is fine actually
it's
it's tight up to which polynomial so
the interesting question is is can it
actually be exp
can it be actually something like
epsilon to the n or
does it have to be some function of n
maybe two to the n
and then polynomial in epsilon for
example that's
if i had to guess i would say that the
rate of convergence
is some function of n which can be
pretty terrible we know that you need
interaction after all to solve
like even uh nissan vectors and so on so
you you know that you cannot get away
with very few rounds if you have some
complicated function
but this trouble is a function of n
because it also applies to communication
and then the tail when you have more and
more rounds and manage to reduce
information i believe should behave
something like this
or some polynomial in epsilon but that's
that's open
whether epsilon to the n is necessary or
it's f of n
times poly epsilon uh
and then looking at other quantities so
i think the most closely related is
the amount of entanglement needed in to
prove or quantum games but
uh basically
to see if if anything from what we
learned can can be helpful there
okay so uh this concludes the technical
part
of the talk so i wanted to tell you
about the program in paris
uh to announce a program in paris next
year so but maybe i should take
questions first
okay all right so uh
some of you are actually participating
in organizing it but
so we are organizing a program
at the institute in ripon carre in paris
uh
called nexus of information computation
theories
so this is basically the main messages
this website
uh and so it's organized
by organized with bubak nazar with a
noob
and with aslan uh from
paris and
so we have it's a 10-week program
in addition to a boot camp and a
flagship workshop there are four themes
two two week long each and
so those are the titles and
essentially all the information about is
is
on this website and
so hope to see many of
you there as well and talk to us or look
it up there
right thanks
thank you thanks